[Music]
Darvin and it's compounds form an
integral part of our lives from food to
medicines from textiles to laboratories
these organic compounds find a place
everywhere
we have seen carbon compounds having
magical applications as well
right from killing microorganisms to
cleaning our clothes they perform
numerous amazing tasks did I just say
cleaning our clothes we're two organic
compounds come into picture for cleaning
clothes
can you guess that's right in the form
of soaps wait what our soaps carbon
compounds yes they are soaps are
chemically the salts of fatty acids
let's understand this fatty acids are
extremely long chains of hydrocarbons
with carboxylic acid attached at one
terminal now since soaps are salts of
fatty acids they have sodium or
potassium attached to the chain so can
you guess the structure let me help you
with that a long chain of hydrocarbons
which can be saturated or unsaturated
and the chain will have a carboxyl
terminal and sodium or potassium
attached to it the structure of a
typical soap appears somewhat like this
how can they be represented though
chemically soaps are represented as RC
double ona or RC double okay depending
upon whether it has sodium or potassium
attached to it now it's obvious that
these kind of huge structures cannot be
written precisely every time that is the
reason why we represent soap molecules
using this structure the ball on top
represents the carboxyl terminal with
sodium or potassium attached this end is
called the hydrophilic end or the head
region but why is it given such a name
Hydra is water as we know and Phyllis is
loving that means the end that loves
being around or being with water in
contrast this terminal is called the
hydrophobic end or the tail region
phobia as we know is fear
that means the group that fears being
with water it is the portion that tries
being away from water
hence this hydrophilic part which gets
attracted towards polar molecules like
water is also referred to as the polar
end and what will this region be called
you guessed it right it's called the
nonpolar end as it gets attracted
towards nonpolar molecules like oil
grease and so on now that we know the
typical structure of a soap molecule
let's understand how it helps us clean
our clothes or vessels see you in the
next video
[Music]